hey guys I'm out of the country but we
didn't want to leave you hanging with no
good news so here's something positive
that happened
it's bizarre that we've come to this
point where
um like free speech used to be a left or
liberal value and and yet we see uh from
you know in quotes left uh a desire to
actually censor
um and uh
that seems crazy I mean I think we
should be extremely concerned about
anything that uh
undermines the First Amendment there's a
reason for the First Amendment
um the first amendment is because people
came from countries where they could not
speak freely
and and where and we're saying certain
things would get you thrown into prison
and they're like well we don't want that
here
and by the way in many parts of the
world
including possible that people might
think are relatively similar to the
United States the the speech laws are
draconian England is quite different I
won't name any countries but
um
why we protecting them they have no
first event it's very easy to prove
liable in England whereas here it's in
England
um
I wouldn't want to say the wrong thing
or uh yes you could be sued easier there
I mean there are a lot in in France I
think if you deny the Holocaust which I
think is abhorrent but I also think it
should be part of free speech right you
can be thrown into jail okay so this my
I I really can't emphasize this enough
we must uh uh we must protect free
speech um and Free Speech only matters
it's only relevant when it's someone you
don't like saying something much like
because obviously every speech that you
like is uh yes that's easy
um so it it's uh and it's the thing
about censorship is that sure for those
who would Advocate it um just remember
at some point that will be turned on you
[Applause]
foreign